mention horror movies about cults
and fans can list titles both new and
old
but some are far scarier than others
whether they're about
hippie devil worshipers or british
pagans
these horror movies all feature some
truly terrifying cults
england's hammer films briefly stepped
away from its cycle of gothic horror
for this exciting 1968 adaptation of
dennis wheatley's novel
the devil rides out about a satanic
cult's pursuit of a pair of unwilling
initiates
hammer star christopher lee took the
heroic route here
as the suave occultist and adventurer
defending two people against a
diabolical devil worshiper
played by charles gray the script by
legendary i am legend author richard
matheson
streamlines the novel into a series of
thrilling set pieces
including an all-night assault by
various spirits
including the angel of death while lee
and his companions protect themselves
from inside the confines of a pentacle
diagram
as depictions of cults go the film
succeeds at portraying the
overpowering mind control the villain
needs only his velvety voice
and piercing eyes to suggest tremendous
psychic power
used to hold acolytes as well as the
extreme
lengths a cult will go to in order to
retain them
the film's depiction of a satanic ritual
complete with the appearance of a
demonic
goat-headed figure also strikes the
right balance of frenzy
terror and ecstasy when hippie satanists
force-feed lsd to a small-town baker
his grandson gets revenge by selling
them meat pies
laced with the blood of a rabid dog the
cultists turn homicidal
and not only lay waste to the town but
they also
spread the disease to the locals one of
the first films to receive an
x rating for violence david durston's
low budget
early 70s freak out i drink your blood
has its
share of dated dialogue and off-kilter
scenes
but as the disease claims more victims
and the rabid cultists and townsfolk
butcher each other the film becomes a
surprisingly graphic
and intense viewing experience that
builds to a nail-biting siege
intentional or not it's hard to not see
the films clash between hippies
and blue-collar workers as some kind of
statement on fears about the
counter-culture
which at the time of the film's release
were fully ablaze
thanks to a real-life cult leader
charles manson
whose crimes inspired durston's script
while most of the cults in the films
mentioned in this list are openly
diabolical the religion practiced in
1973's the wicker man
isn't entirely sinister at least at
first
the people of summer isle a tiny island
off the coast of scotland
follow a pagan practice connected to
many ancient traditions
we've got mayday celebrations complete
with a maypole
a spiritual connection to nature and the
belief that sacrifice will result in a
fruitful harvest
that the sacrifice in question is human
isn't
inherently evil in the eyes of the
island's leader
and his constituents but instead they
view it as a centuries-old tradition
however visiting english policeman neil
howie
played by actor edward woodward whose
devout christianity
and virginal status make him an object
of keen interest
among summer isles locals would
undoubtedly agree
especially in the horror film's shocking
conclusion
that split perspective what's monstrous
to some is just a part of life to others
is what endeared the wicker man to
horror fans for decades
especially among the folk horror
movement which considers the film a
forerunner to major titles in that
sub-genre
the witch the ritual and mid-summer
all owe a debt to this movie oh
and that 2006 remake with nicolas cage
don't bother even for a laugh
not the beast satanic mayhem meets
gear grinding action in 1975's race with
the devil
a favorite of drive-in and grindhouse
aficionados
for its mix of horror and vehicular
stunts
peter fonda and the great warren oates
star as motorcycle
salesman piloting an rv to a vacation in
colorado with their wives
the trip is derailed on a lonely stretch
of texas road
where the couples witness a ritual that
culminates in
human sacrifice what follows is the
traditional paranoia
plot line in many cult-based horror
films with
fonda and oates discovering that their
efforts to bring the murder to light
only reveal that the law townspeople
and even a bar band are in cahoots with
the diabolical worshipers
unlike other protagonists in their
position fonda
and oates fight back against the
sinister cabal
resulting in some high octane action set
pieces
including a ferocious highway pursuit
that rivals
big budget studio productions for sheer
bravado
it's a mix of brilliant horror and
brilliant stunts that results in one of
the most
crowd-pleasing cold horror films of the
1970s
at first blush english writer director
ben wheatley's 2011 film
kill list plays as a dark psychological
thriller
with a troubled military veteran
channeling his simmering rage into work
as a hitman
but as he and his gun-toting partner
brutally work their way through a list
of targets
it slowly becomes apparent that both the
intended victims
and their mysterious employer are
somehow linked to a shadowy pagan cult
with far-ranging influence and an
appetite
for sacrifice shot in just 18 days
and largely improvised by its cast kill
list
raises many questions but leaves most
unanswered by its devastating conclusion
in doing so wheatley allows our own
fears about the cult's intention
and its members to run rampant upping
the paranoia and disorientation that's a
key element of the plot
for most horror movies about dangerous
cults and if you want more films like
kill list wheatley has continued to
explore the world of secret
organizations
and identities in a diverse array of
films
from the dystopian high-rise and the
psychedelic folk horror of a field in
england
to the latest adaptation of daphne du
maurier's classic thriller
rebecca charles manson and his followers
also known as the family have been the
focus of countless films and television
projects including two adaptations of
helter skelter
quentin tarantino's once upon a time in
hollywood
the netflix series mind hunter and even
a bizarre
stop-motion animated film called live
freaky die freaky
but one of the most grueling depictions
of life on the spawn ranch
where manson and his followers lived is
the 1997 feature titled simply
the manson family the independent
feature
which took more than a decade to
complete gives no quarter in depicting
the horrific mind games
and physical abuse that were a
requirement to living under manson's
command
as well as the ghastly killings of
actress sharon tate
and her companions in august 1969
but even more harrowing is the film's
wrap-around story
which follows a modern day television
news reporter's efforts
to compile a documentary segment on the
deaths
in these scenes the film masterfully
cuts between interviews with aging
family members
long behind bars but still clearly
damaged
and glimpses of a drug-addicted punk
goth gang
inching closer to forming their own
family showing just how long
and destructive the shadow of the cult
mindset can be
the individual stories in the three
films that comprise the vhs
trilogy of found footage horror can be
hit or miss
but nearly every fan of the franchise
agrees that the most full-tilled crazy
gore-soaked entry is safe haven from
2013's vhs
2. the story begins with a news crew
conducting an
investigation into an obscure indonesian
cult
but as they probe deeper into the
group's activities
it becomes apparent that the cult is
preparing for a reckoning which entails
mass suicide zombies gallons of blood
and ultimately a monstrous supernatural
entity
the film unleashes these horrors at a
breakneck pace that barely allows the
viewer to comprehend
what they're seeing before the next
nightmare makes its presence known
that's intense and overpowering but
equally unsettling is the cult member's
mindless self-destruction
as the reckoning takes root which echoes
the terrible
real-life events at jonestown the waco
siege
and heaven's gate before you dive into
the mind-expanding cosmic terror of
2017's the
endless you may want to consider
checking out resolution
a 2012 prequel of sorts by writers
producers directors
justin benson and aaron morehead it's
not necessary
but it does offer a dive into the core
ideas in the
endless which begins with two brothers
returning to an encounter group they
belong to as young men
and which may or may not have been an
apocalyptic ufo cult
the true nature of what happened at the
camp eventually becomes
secondary to the dawning realization
that time and reality there may be under
the control of an unseen
but ever-present being over time
the brothers and their fellow campers
all of whom appear to have remained
exactly the same despite the passage of
several years
are subjected to nightmarish temporal
loops with no hopes of escape
though the true nature of what happens
in the endless
they appear to touch on science fiction
the filmmaker's decision to filter the
action through a cult scenario is spot
on as issues of depersonalization
separation from the outside world and
salvation by unseen entities based on
degrees of faith
are also some of the most frightening
elements of a cult experience
paranoia is of course a key ingredient
in horror movies about
cults and the notion that seemingly
normal people can embrace dangerous or
destructive ideas as the gospel truth
is one of the key reasons why genre
directors continue to return to these
groups for fresh
and frightening material one of the best
indie films to dive deeply into the
secret beliefs of cults
is karen kusama's 2015 feature
the invitation it begins in territory
that anyone would find
unsettling a dinner party thrown by a
former significant
other and from there it quietly drifts
into even more unpleasant waters
with the realization that the hosts are
going to use the event to showcase
a recent experience the last thing i
want you guys to think is that i'm
trying to
force my ideas on you but what the hosts
are selling to their guests
including a former spouse and several
friends is a new age style
grief support system unfortunately it's
one that helps members overcome trauma
by passing it along to others in the
most literal way
by killing them the realization of the
cult's intention
and the guest's attempts to escape are
terrifying
and it all culminates with one of the
greatest final shots in horror history
though there are satanists behind the
harrowing events in writer director
ari astor's feature debut hereditary
the worshippers of the demon king
payment are more a coven than a cult
but his sophomore film 2019's mid-summer
is firmly based around a cult
specifically
a scandinavian pagan cult that offers a
traumatized outsider
a chance at redemption and unpleasant
ends for her skeptical companions
as with the wicker man midsummer asks
the viewer to question if the cult's
rights are inherently evil
or holdovers from an older and more
brutal
way of life that debate comes into sharp
focus
with florence pugh's character danny
who's been emotionally steamrolled by a
family tragedy
and her non-committal boyfriend the
cult's rights are focused on renewal
rebirth and transformation and if anyone
seems like an ideal candidate for those
gifts
it's danny whose feelings grow more
complicated as the film wears on
of course that transformation doesn't
come without a little pain
and therein lies the real terror at the
heart
of cult horror movies check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one